[Music]  being at home is not that much helpful  as much as being in school with others  since the world has taught because of  pandemic but the people of kashmir have  suffered something else  [Music]  this has resulted  in a huge academic loss and obviously it  could  lead to a generational loss the  facilities particularly of the internet  online classes the facilities which  other students had  in india and other parts of the world  our children did not have those  facilities it has been about two and a  half years since  kovat  is going on and our children  had a lot of impact on their  mental health because  they could not  go out anywhere  [Music]  it was an excellent experience to rejoin  school after such a long time gap  and our school our teachers welcomed us  in a very appreciative manner obviously  everybody is happy to see children back  [Music]  teachers  [Music]